So, this is where we turn to NuPrl. As
I mentioned already, NuPrl is a theoretical framework. And there
is a way by which the OCaml code can
be converted to NuPrl code. There is a tool that
allows that transformation to be done very simply. We
use that tool to convert the unoptimized OCaml code to
the NuPrl code and once you have the NuPrl
code, then we can roll up our sleeves and say
how do we go about optimizing this NuPrl
code. There are two step process for this.
The first step is what is called static
optimization and this requires that a NuPrl expert
and the OCaml expert sit together and, in
a semi-automatic manner, they go layer by layer
in the protocol stack, and identify what transformation
code can be applied in order to optimize
each of the layers. We're not going across
layers, but for every layer we're asking the
question, is it possible to simplify the functionality
of what is happening in one layer by
looking at the NuPrl code and using the
NuPrl framework and the optimization theorems that is
part of that framework to come up with
a more optimized implementation of each and every one
of these layers. That's what we're doing in this
first step. This is where both the NuPrl expert and
the OCaml expert have to sit together because you want
the NuPrl expert to know whether the optimization that they
are attempting to do is kosher with respect to the
functionality that is desired in the OCaml code. And that's
why this is semi-automatic. Because the optimization itself can be
done, using the theorem proving framework. But whether that optimization
is an appropriate one or not is something that
has to be verified with manual intervention. And the kinds
of code transformation that can be done, are things
like function inlining. If you have function calls, then you
can make them inline. And that is one way
of optimizing it within a layer. And directed equality substitution
is another optimization that can be done. There are some
things that are very specific to functional programming, leading to
code simplicity. And all of those things are
what is being done in the static optimization
of every layer in the protocol stack. Remember
we are not going across layers, but every layer
we're doing the static optimization. This is good,
but unfortunately, that's not enough. Because we have lots
of layers between a message arriving and the
application getting that message or vice versa. And what
we want to be able to do is, if possible, collapse all these layers. Because
when you go through these multiple layers we're adding latency to the overall
processing of any message. And this is where we are going to turn to
the power of the NuPrl theorem proving
framework. So the next step is dynamic optimization.
Which is attempting to collapse these multiple layers, and
it is completely automatic. The previous one I said, layer
by layer, we're doing semi automatic fashion, there's completely automatic,
and it is the power of that theorem proving framework
which is actually going do that for you. And in
order for that theorem proving framework to do this work,
what we need to identify is, what are common things
that happen in order to do this collapsing of layers.